hi my name is
francisco rodriguez i'm from world front
research south america
and i will talk about geodata and this
year i will focus on
vector geographics so in this
presentation
[Music]
we will talk all about the data that is
behind this new vector geographics all
this technology we have
been developing to support this
well we expect all this to be included
in version 12.2
of warfarin language
this is a small outline of this
presentation
okay so this is the map you get for
your graphics here
and then
then here we have the
traditional geographics map which is a
which come with
raster tiles it means that we have in
the server
bitmaps of every tile in the world and
for the ones we don't have that
we generate that on the fly because of
course we cannot have
that many times because we need that up
to zoom 80.
now we have started this support for
vector geographics which look much
better in the sense that
they are actual primitives in rendered
by
your computer so you can resize you can
see how sharp all the lines should be
because they are going to be rendered by
your client
so this is for exactly the same area
using the same zoom
so that's what we should be able to do
now
so let's see some examples
and to as introduction to all these
examples
we have added now also very uh various
styles so in order to access this
new vector your graphics
you can use the yo background option so
instead of using street map
stream map no labels etc now we have
added vector classic vector default
vector business
vector marketing minimum monochrome web
and vintage
so the idea is that now with these two
backgrounds
everybody will be able to get
these vector maps
so this is a small
[Music]
set of all the world
maps soon level 0
for all the styles so street map is the
current geographics and all these are
the new styles
that will be available we are still
working on all these styles so expect
some changes from what
i'm showing right now but
this is a preview
so also something very nice about these
new vector maps is that
we can have now projections
without distortion so for the raster
maps for example
you have geographics which by default
for example when you use a non
like rectangular or mercator projection
uses the no labels map
because when you add the labels when you
use the
current stream map they get distorted
and that's because they change of the
coordinates and
how we project the whole earth now
now with vector map we can ask for the
projection
and using this new background vector
classic it will show very nice all the
labels without any issues
because they are added as output
primitives so these are text
elements into this graphics box
so let's see a few more uh maps in this
gallery
for example at country level maps at
country level maps you can expect
limits between countries limits between
some states
some mistake names capital
city names etc so this is something that
of course with the styles we will be
able also to
tweak even more to have very nice
maps i have also here the
zoom level 4 we have many zoom levels i
will explain that a bit later
so for example for united kingdom
with a different style i will be using
different
styles for each map so that we can
appreciate them all
and we can see how the
coastlines are sometimes having let's
say
simplify it and that depends on the zoom
level
we choose geographics will try to choose
the best
zoom level for each map so that it
doesn't have
that many data
and for example a smaller country like
vatican city also looks very nice
and you can see all the elements around
streets
buildings different blocks etc
so let's see some city level maps for
example for new york well
a new york city is very large there is
no match
soon get there
or let's ask for moscow
and let's for some some level
i'm using the opposition to actually
look for the center of moscow
instead of uh looking for the full
polygon because
it's going to be larger as you can see
there are no issues with cyrillic
letters
we can go deeper let's go to zoom 15
for tokyo for example
there is some center position within
tokyo
or we can navigate to other cities let's
go to
stockholm for example where we can see
the different elements
all drawing into the graphics
we can go deeper like zoom 17 and look
for the tower of london
where you can even see some of the
buildings etc that are in
the data currently we are still using
some
uh let's say
all data and we are working on updating
all these data so
for the release we expect to have
totally updated
vector database or we can even have
uh decimal values for the zoom levels
that's something now allowed and also
something that works smoothly with
the vector geographics
for example the central plaza in mexico
city
with samsung of 17.5
so let's talk about a bit about the
types
jose has been already talking about how
we are merging types etc so this is a
small reminder of
how the tags work
so you know that we are organizing the
vector
maps also using tiles and
for each zoom we have
two elevated to the zoom twice
so this is a very large number for large
zoom levels
and well when i post
the node you will see here the code
to create for example these bounding
boxes that represent each style in
different zoom levels i'm using here
maps at different zoom levels
and representing which are the types
that
make up this map
so for example if we want to draw europe
at zoom 3
we will have this number of tiles
and what will happen if we want to
draw this hat soon for where you can
have more elements
like for example more rivers more limits
between
estate etc
much more detail the city's capital
cities but you will have a lot of more
uh
types
so a bit about the zoom levels so we
have some levels from
zoom zero to zoom 14
and you can anyway as you have seen
before request
for example a map at zoom 16 at zoom 17
not zoom
even 24 but anyway we will use the data
from the zoom 14.
the difference is that there could be
more elements in the sense that the
style could define more
style layers i will explain later about
the side layers
and then with these style layers
they can choose different elements from
the same types
and of course the total number of tiles
in the server is going to be this
large number
and that's enough to cover all the data
in the world so
that's several gigabytes of data in the
servers
so yes and to optimize
a bit how these styles work
we are using what we call meta tiles
that's something that also the raster
server uses internally but not
externally but in this case we are using
that
we are developing that in the clients
client side
that means that we are grouping the
tiles by
in groups of 8x8
tiles such way that for example this map
of europe
that used 70 tiles
regular tiles now uses only two metals
in that way even when the total download
size is larger the times you request
you do request to the server is much
smaller
so it means in general a better
performance
downloading the data and also allows you
to for example
if you do several maps
it will have the meta types in the
catcher of your client so it will
work faster other maps
okay so how about the tiles itself
we are using the mapbox vector tile
specification
as format for the tiles which is encoded
using the google protocol buffer
and in general each style is a
collection of
layers of data this data is a set of
features and
each one has is this basic object like
for example
a line a polio
so the content of each one is a type
which we'll say if it's a point a line
or volume
the geometry itself it makes the actual
coordinates for this line this point or
polio
and some key value pairs which are the
metadata of this
element for example the polygon of
[Music]
us so that's going to be a a polygon
type geometry the geometry will be the
actual coordinates and
it will have some metadata like the name
the class etc actually the
borders of countries are not polygons
but lines
because you want for example to draw a
line between two countries
and a different line in the ocean
limits borders etc
so these are the type and
[Music]
these key values are actually used to
by the styles to filter and select the
different features for example
if we want to draw only the capital
cities we can use the
the class city and uh well
there is another key value which says if
it's a capital or not
there is a capital key with some value
to specify its country capital there are
several
keys actually for different layers
there could be different keys
so the styles are we are using
internally the mapbox style
specification
and in this specification
the styles are defined by different
layers
these layers are actually different from
the layers of the data but could be
related
because for example you can have a layer
for the names of the
streets and another layer for the actual
lines of the streets
in the style but they too these two
layers
refer to the same data layer of streets
of transportation it's called
so the main layers the style layers are
the background
which is actually only for the color of
the background
the lantern color fill type
layers which are the polygons lines
for the cases of borders for example
reverse streets
and symbols symbol is the layer that
holds all the this time layer that holds
all the
labels so all the labeling goes in the
simple layer
as i said in general each of these
layers might refer to
a source layer
and each one will define some filters
some
let's say with the key values to
pick up which elements from each source
layer
are going to be applied in the map
and which which
will use some parameters of paint and
layout
by paying parameters we need for example
to choose which color
opacity if there is a pattern if there
is some outline color for
the field case for example and the
layout parameters
are many more like for example
the nine weed line cup and join
some parameters extra for for them
some important parameter for the symbols
is where to place a symbol
i will explain a bit more later
different
parameters like for example the text
field parameter that means
what are we going to use as label font
style parameters like
family size letter spacing line height
alignment how with
i want the labels if i want them to
rotate or not
in which direction if there is any
offset
if we want to keep upright the labels
for example
when we follow a line a label could be
upside down and we need to rotate that
180 degrees but we
might want or not might want that for
example if we have an icon with an arrow
we don't want to
move that arbitrarily but if we want a
text we want
that to be something you can read always
which i can imagine to use
how much space between the different
symbols well there is simple space in
text spacing icon spacing
so there is a lot of parameters that we
have
that we needed to implement to interpret
all these style
layers of these these different types
so i created a small function
to handle well to show how these
style layers work internally
so here is a full map of what you can
see the parameters of the map here
or the wall at zoom 2 some size
using multiplicator projection and using
this new vector default
button
so these are the different types of
style layers so we have the
fill style layers the line style layers
the single style layers well some extra
layer so let's remove everything
so the background is basically as i said
the color
for the land the fill
layers are all the polygons in this case
basically the polygons are the
ocean and seas so all the water polios
then we have the lines which for this
map
kind of following only the borders
and the symbols which are all the
country names and cnames
[Music]
well some attribution that it's a the
tooltip that will replace
and now we can also see the
different styles so for example we have
the the background is the same
style layer so these are the the styles
file
that we handle it's handling actually
these names
in the file so these are the ones that
we are interpreting
these are the different classifications
so there is some ice over there
this is the water so all the ocean comes
as a
large polio
we have the boundaries of the countries
we have for example the names of some
seas
the name of the oceans
and different layers of names of
countries
this is known to why to have
these different layers is to give a
different priority
i will explain then in a moment
how the labels work so they need to have
a different priority so they are in
different
layers
well all these refer to different
layers in the source so in the source of
the tiles we have a layer for the land
cover a different layer for the water
a different layer for the boundaries
the water names here for example we have
two different
with layers that refer to this same
source layer or the place names
which means that two different layers
refer to the same
with three different style layers refer
to the same source layer
and let's see now uh another assume
that this is i think zoom nine point
something this is four
so you can see here the parameters i
used so my size
same projection and here we have a lot
of more
styles so all this has to be computed by
the
biographics and when i
i won't play with each one but then you
can play with this
so we have well let's see for example
all the polygons
these are all the polygons around the
river it's
also this water polygon the parks
different elements
lines there there are lots of different
lines
going on here and
the different types of symbols
of these symbols we are still working on
improving this even more
so you you can see here all the
different layers for example that i can
choose
only the transportation names
or only the water names well
it seems that some might be outside and
this is something else that i wanted to
to say before i move on is that
when you are looking at some of these
maps with all these elements actually
we have many more elements around
[Music]
and this is to have let's see if yes
to have the names to know that
in case some of these names also go
inside this
region of the map so this is the buffer
that also was talking about
jose that all the ties comes with some
buffer of data so
we can draw them properly inside this
smaller square
so let's go over the labels the labels
it's actually the most uh let's say
hard part to implement in the sense that
we need to implement all this uh
technology to handle them the labels in
there
are a text an icon or an icon plus a
text
and there are different places where you
can put the label
it can be in a point let's say i have a
name here
it can be part of a line for example a
highway
or a river you can have a fixer's
rotation
or that rotates following the line or it
can be in the line center
so let's go very quick i can already
show you this is
an example of point names so there is a
point
where we want to place the country name
or ocean name
line names for example to follow the
rivers here for example this is a
conjunction of maranon and
kayali that then converts into amazonas
river
or a long lines but
that don't protect for example shields
for for the highways the roads
we don't want to rotate them so we want
to rotate the stream names but not the
highways
so this is a different type of placement
so we need to use the algorithm to
handle the collisions for example if we
if we
don't use that algorithms we will get
maps like this with all the country
names
with all the oceans names for example
for some
two or four zoom 14 for example for
madrid
we have a lot lot of elements here
so we need to use
[Music]
jose's algorithm that he already
explained within the
in his presentation so we start with an
empty
let's say a list of used boxes
and then we iterate for each layer
in this list of layers that i
showed before
we go from bottom to top and start
iterating over the layers
so we compute the bonding box of each
layer of
each label and then if it's a
label for a line we try to compute the
best position in each
line to place that then we call the
conditional algorithm with all the
parameters about the spacing
for each bonding box for all the bonding
boxes
and then we select which one are
included and
we fill this list of user boxes with the
new labels and iterate again in the next
layer
so effectively the priority of each
label will be
by the layer it belongs and also
with within the same layer we use the
order of the labels
as they come so so we need to sort the
data in the source if we want some
specific ordering
so for for example after applying that
to the world
we get these labels which are only 53
[Music]
out of the 220 that were here so
here in this first map we have around
220 but not around exactly 220
labels that were computed and for the
next map
as you can see there are now nicely only
some elements
and here we have different nine
different layers of labels
and the collision algorithm selected 202
labels out of
almost 8 000 labels
and of course if you go to higher zones
you will have many more labels to to
to handle and all this is done in
in some milliseconds so all this
collision algorithm is
very optimized to handle all these large
number of data points
so something else about this label
labeling of maps is that the labels
depend on the
on the map size so if for the same zoom
level let's say some level three
if you use a size of 200 pixels it will
show only a few labels if you the same
data the same map
parameters with more size which are more
labels and
obviously with more size will show even
more labels
[Music]
and something else is that in general
the labels are
text elements that means that they don't
they don't rescale
when you resize everything is scaled but
we have also a methods parameter
that will allow you to to rescan the
labels
while you increase or decrease
so they will keep the same scale size
that's a metal parameter that
we will be able to access
and well we are almost over the time
some
before the questions some of the future
work we
plan to extend and improve more the
support of vectorio graphics
we want to allow layer manipulation
right now it's
kind of behind the scenes support
styles provided by the users then also
support external providers
and eventually also direct data x
that's good for the future
and well that's all from me and let's
see if there are some
questions
okay so for now we are
that's some support in different
languages it's going to be possible
because
uh the the data has
the names in all the languages that's
right and
that's something that depends on the
style so
we should be able to support for example
a vector classic in english a vector
classic in
japanese et cetera that's something that
if the label is
read in japanese or in english that's
something we will try
we can try to support but that's
something up to the style more than to
the data
so this vector service is actually
done everything in
the back end is going to be where the
actual list these are static
pvf files and meta tiles that we are
processing and everything is done within
the garment so we are not using any
java service or javascript service or
javascript library so we are
implementing all uh
at a mathematical level and at kernel
and see that's why
we are how we are getting a fast uh
way to compute all the label collisions
cetera so we are computing everything
internally in the kernel of mathematic
uh the time lag for openstreetmap so
well that's something that now with the
vector
data i think we will be able to
to update more frequently because that's
easier to handle
somehow in the back end but we are still
working on how to provide always updated
data for
open openstreetmap
okay i annoy them more questions
well i think we are over time if there
are no more questions
thanks for attending and well
any more questions you can contact me i
will be around
throughout the conference thanks bye
you